all right let's go back to the Discord
lines and hear from some more people in
the audience davidpackman.com
Discord of course is the only place the
only place to call into the show
important to understand their accept no
substitution I think is the point that
I'm trying to make let's go to Josh from
Michigan Josh from Michigan welcome to
the program what's on your mind
hi David cool uh it's nice to uh touch
base here
um I was just thinking about I I look at
uh the
270towin.com uh app and and I look at
the map and I see all you really need to
have a stable Democratic president going
into the future our existing blue States
plus Wisconsin Michigan and Pennsylvania
and the existing problem these three
states have are sort of loss of
population or stagnating population and
my question is kind of what do you think
these three states can do to sort of
gain population and and
stay strong for a more Progressive
future because that's that's kind of
where I'm coming from well let me
propose something different to you Josh
you're not wrong that one way if you
hold voter turnout level one way for
Democrats to do better in those States
would be to get people to move to those
States who would vote for Democrats
certainly that's possible I think that
there's an easier way though it's much
easier to get an existing Wisconsin
resident who doesn't care enough to vote
to go and vote than it is to get someone
from like Connecticut to move to
Wisconsin do you understand the point
I'm making
yeah that makes a lot of sense in other
words you have the voters both parties
have the voters to win because voter
turnout is so pathetically low in the
United States I think it's far easier to
convince existing wisconsinites and
michiganders or whatever the right term
is
um to just go and vote rather than to
try to get people to move there and the
truth is getting people to move
somewhere depends on so many things
really beyond our conversational control
you can convince people to vote just
through a conversation about why it's
important and it doesn't require them to
sell and buy a new house find a job rent
a U-Haul or any of those things so I
think the focus should be not on getting
people to move to these key States but
just activating uh voters I will say one
other thing just because you brought
this up one of the real questions about
2024 is okay so whether it's Trump Biden
or Biden DeSantis or whatever
if we start with the 2020 map
we then have to say what is the path for
Republicans to win and when you start
looking it's not a great path for
Republicans now I'm not saying Biden's
got this I'm not saying that by any
means but you look at some of these
states Trump got Florida in 2020. so you
don't even have to worry like Biden won
and didn't get Florida imagine that
Georgia which Biden won went to the
Republican which it often does that
still leaves Democrats with 290
electoral votes imagine that Republicans
also get Arizona back which I think has
gone more blue Josh since 2020.
Democrats still have 279. so the the
point here is not that Republicans can't
win or whatever my point is if I think
about 2020 and think about what's
changed I think Georgia has stayed as
purple as it was I think Arizona has
gone more blue and so Republicans do
have some work to do to get to 270 votes
in 2024.
yeah I totally agree yeah they have a
lot of work to do
um and I I think Michigan for for what
it's worth has gone a little bit left
since 2020
um 2022 it went for Gretchen Whitmer by
11 yep uh and she's done some positive
things here
um a little bit slower on the clip than
Minnesota but um just foundational stuff
that I think is going to be great for
the future of the state here
excellent stuff all right Josh thank you
so much for the call
you're welcome all right there goes Josh
from Michigan with I mean those are
important issues Nitty Gritty Nitty
Gritty stuff for sure 30 million trees
are destroyed every year for toilet
paper in the U.S alone so toilet paper
is a big contributor to deforestation
and climate change our sponsor real
paper makes toilet paper from bamboo
bamboo plants keep growing which means
no deforestation bamboo also absorbs
five times as much carbon from the
atmosphere as pine trees and bamboo
toilet paper is stronger than regular
toilet paper and even softer so bamboo
toilet paper is all around a win for you
and for the environment it's time to
move on from that toilet paper from
trees that you're using at home when you
use real paper it doesn't feel like
you're sacrificing anything it's soft
and fluffy and they'll ship it to your
door in plastic free packaging on a
schedule super easy with every box of
real paper you buy they are funding
reforestation efforts across the country
through their partnership with one tree
planted so unlike the toilet paper that
cuts down trees real is helping to
actively plant them go to realpaper.com
Pacman and use code Pacman for 30 off
your first order and free shipping the
link is down below